okay first uh brienne georgia
is sassy classy smart and a lot of
mystery
um how much fun did you have playing
this character with the dark past
you know that kept us guessing i had the
most fun
georgia doesn't follow the rules she's
confident she's calculated she knows
what she's doing
she loves her kids she's obsessed with
them
and georgia you know it's george's way
or the highway yeah
uh antonio antonia am i saying that
correctly yes but you can call me tony
it's fine
okay tony okay um so tony now everyone
is calling this show the next gilmore
girls which is of course you know a much
loved series still to this day so
how do you feel about that comparison
and were you both fans of the series
it's definitely very flattering um i
didn't grow up
watching gilmore girls but i had always
heard about it i knew it was super super
popular so my mother and i actually saw
the first three seasons of it before i
went to canada and then she ended up
finishing the rest and
um that's really great but this show is
just so so different and i think
people will really realize that right
off the bat it's it's dark it's edgy
it's
it's just modern and um really really
surprising
yeah um brienne what would you say are
some of the major themes throughout the
series
coming of age at its heart that's what
the show is all about it's
growing up your identity mother-daughter
relationships there's a lot of
it's really grounded in the high school
experience so it's also about a lot of
emotional and physical firsts yeah
awesome um so tony what i loved most
about the series um is the fact that
your character doesn't shy away from
topics like racism
and mental health so you know how does
it feel knowing that your struggles as
as your character you know create a
platform for other people and for people
to feel
seen i think it is very very important
and i and i felt immediately
grateful and happy to be a part of such
a special and personal project
although jenny and i are two completely
different people we are
very very much alike through all of our
vulnerabilities and
teenagers everywhere struggle with
identity whether it's their sexual
identity
their racial identity anywhere they fit
they want to try and fit in and so
for ginny she's trying to figure out all
of the layers to herself
and it's really confusing and it's
stressful and i think it's realistic
and so i'm very very happy to see it
awesome
brienne what do you want people to take
away from the series of anything
i want people to be able to identify
with the show
i hope it can help start to create
conversations around some uncomfortable
subjects i hope
people feel seen and most of all i hope
they enjoy it i hope they have as much
fun watching it as we did making it
aw um tony so for the black community
the people you know that your character
speaks to in this
um you as a person you know what message
would you have for them
just in terms of being seen in this show
blackness is just as multifaceted as
any other culture as anyone in any part
of anyone's life
and it's a human experience and i think
it's
very very important to show the
different facets of that you know ginny
is biracial
that's in and of itself a very unique
experience and
you know her father is black and there
are characters in the show
that have really really layered
identities and i think the black
community is just so rich
um and so diverse that it's really
really important to showcase that